so why should you be creating content  on tick tock for your startup i  personally  believe that tick tock is the easiest  video platform for business owners  and that's because there's a little bit  less creativity involved compared to  creating content on youtube or facebook  instead of having to come up with a  large majority of the ideas on your own  you want to look at who are the trend  setters within your space  and copy their content or copy their  trends and make those trends your own  the really nice thing about the tiktok  algorithm is that it does the work  for you if you create really engaging  content  engaging content will get people to stay  over a long period of time and tick tock  will show that content  to more people